we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p the san antonio
troll is known for one thing on this
show for nearly a decade he calls in and
criticizes me for things i have never
said a particularly manic troll from san
antonio called in unable to control
himself still criticizing me for things
i certainly never said
oh sorry let's take it from the top
uh pac-man i'm just wondering do you
ever do a video oh something seriously
wrong with your body you know don't mess
with the bridge of death oh joe
i i mean i've i don't know i've never
said trump's on the verge of death i
don't even know what this is in
reference to coughs are sniffles
you know you've done this about
everywhere not like none of them have
died i think hurricane is the only one
that died we look older on the verge of
that they're about to die
well
when it's been reported that people are
actually on the verge of death like the
many radio hosts who were you know in a
in a medically induced coma for weeks
and it was reported they are on the
verge of death we would we would but do
i would report that but do you
understand that that's not
my language that's from other media
outlets
but other than that as usual the san
antonio troll furious with me for things
i never said
how does it feel being wrong just so
consistently and i'll tell you something
you
i mean you you go on to say that
desantis is mismanaged covered worse
than any other government you don't even
mention andrew cuomo in fact just saying
andrew coleman's name you already hung
the call up and uh
actually i've criticized cuomo
extensively
uh again
we i don't care about party i don't care
about democrats i don't care about
republicans desantis mismanaged covid
cuomo mismanaged covid in different ways
we've talked about it all san antonio
troll either criticize me for things
i've said or call whoever is saying this
stuff because it certainly is not me we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today get instant access by becoming a
member at joinpakman.com